The names and the stories in this episode have been omitted to protect the
privacy of the individuals involved.
This is Jocko podcast number 37 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo,
good evening and with us tonight.
I am honored to have retired Chief Warrant Officer Roger Hayden here with us
tonight as a guest.
Now,
unless you are in the seal teams or you were in the seal teams,
then you likely don't know who Roger Hayden is.
In fact,
I'm going to go ahead and guarantee you don't know who Roger Hayden is.
There's no book,
there's no movie,
there's no social media,
there's no one to Google.
And I've talked before about how there's three types of guys in the seal teams,
the guys that built the reputation that the seal teams has,
the guys that maintain the reputation of the seal teams,
and then there's the guys that live off the reputation of the seal teams and
usually those guys didn't contribute much to it in the first place.
But let there be no doubt Roger Hayden is without question,
without question.
One of the people,
one of the men responsible for building the reputation of the seal teams.
He did the massive heavy lifting in,
laid down the foundation of everything that the seal teams are in the jungles of
Vietnam and he passed on lessons of combat written in blood that we carry to
this day.
One of the guys here,
Roger Hayden,
that truly forge the attitude that makes the seal teams what the seal teams are
and I'm going to tell you quickly how I first heard of Roger.
So I was back.
I was a new guy at seal team one,
so it's 1991 and back then no one reads,
the seals weren't that popular yet and the old seal Udt seal reunions,
we're not that big of a deal there.
They were just kind of a small little gig down at down at like the lion's club
or something and national city.
Real low key.
But the only guys who,
none of the,
none of the younger seals went to moves all Vietnam seals.
Maybe a couple of World War II guys.
And I was down there.
I was with my,
my running mate at the time,
my good friend who's at seal team one who had gone through Buzzworth guy by the
name of Chris and we were just sitting around talking to some old Vietnam guys
and we were getting pretty fired up.
You know,
it's kind of,
there's,
you don't want,
you pay the $10 fee,
get into this Gig,
there's free beer.
So we were a few beers deep you might say.
And we listen to stories and again,
we're new guys.
This is 1991 we didn't never been in combat.
So we were there to try and learn about the history and learn about the guys.
And finally me being young and dumb and pretty well buzzed,
I asked these two Vietnam guys that we were sitting there talking to,
I said,
hey,
who was the most bad ass burger and mother fucker and seal in Vietnam?
And both these guys looked at me and said,
Roger Hayden,
and I remembered that name.
And when I actually met you for the first time you were,
I'd met you a couple times.
But then when I actually worked with you for the first time,
you were laying greater on a,
on a platoon full mission profile.
And that's actually the first time I learned,
truly understood the concept of cover and move,
which is a basic tactic,
which guys didn't know.
No one had taught it to me.
This was my second platoon.
I'd already been through a workup.
I had the idea in my head,
but here,
and you say it the way you described it,
I said it clicked in my head and I never forgot it.
And I actually wrote about it in the book extreme ownership.
And it's what I talked to all the seals that when I was putting in through
training,
that's what I told him.
One of those fundamental tactics.
And so
that's
kind of my,
my introduction to Roger Hayden.
So Roger,
I know you've actually literally never done an interview before and I want to
thank you for coming on.
It's,
it's a true honor to have you on the podcast.
So welcome.
Yeah,
Roger Hayden here.
Thanks Jocko.
Really appreciate it.
And you're one of my heroes who different environment,
different times.
Did you kicked ass and took names to the um,
I wasn't,
I was uh,
just one of the boys in the,
uh,
in seal team one when I got there and deployed a couple of times with them.
And uh,
our environment was the jungle and we got pretty good at it and went out and
hunted the bad guys.
Nobody else in Vietnam,
as far as I know,
army marines or any of them were to go out at night.
They would usually hold up in a base camp or something like that while we
figured nighttimes when they move around that then we're going to move around
and see if we can find these guys and take 'em out.
And that's all we did.
It isn't,
um,
one guy.
It's a team effort.
Everybody works hard.
I had some great,
great buddies of mine that were,
uh,
I mean my gut and partner was a stoner guy and I was a 60 guy between the two of
us.
He shot a thousand rounds a minute,
nine to five,
five oh seven,
six to my 60.
At a worked out well,
last platoon I was in,
we carried for sixties and five he didn't carry a stoner or a 60 he carried a 16
with a two oh 300 or x nine one 48 for back in the day.
Guys
say those numbers again of how many guys were carrying sixties and stoners.
Four of us were carrying sixties and fire guys carried stoners out of a 14
member too.
That's what we operated.
So for those of you civilians out there that are listening,
that's a lot of firepower.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a way you bring the thunder.
And so we're,
where'd you grow up though,
before you got in the team's,
where'd you grow up?
Basically
my rook and what I look at,
my dad was a carpenter,
so we moved quite a bit around,
but it was a place called rule Nan Montana by the flathead lake in Montana.
Rudy have the mission range in a real,
real brief area.
I grew up green,
breaking horses and stuff like that and uh,
building tree houses and just,
uh,
working on my grandpa's farm and my uncle's ranch and stuff like that.
So that's kind of where I grew up at.
I lived a wild Phoenix,
Arizona on stuff like that.
And,
um,
it says here in the next thing sports.
Well,
I played football outside linebacker.
I boxed her two years in high school and I swam.
My Dad built,
worked on the tram and palm springs.
And when he was there I went to palm springs high school.
So I got on the water polo team there.
So let's say you got a little comfortable in the water.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
So at what point,
what year was it when you actually decided you're going to join the navy?
That was 1965.
And did you know already know about the seal teams will know?
Nope.
Nobody knew about him.
My Dad,
uh,
like you said,
he was a carpenter,
but he was in,
um,
Udt three and it was at swam on the Incheon Harbor in Vietnam.
But I did,
and I'm not Vietnam,
Korea,
but I didn't know anything about it because he never talked about it.
So your dad was a frog?
Yeah,
but I mean that's,
I knew guys that knew him over older guys.
I mean,
when I was young guy,
like you said you were when your document,
you know,
so anyway,
but he never said much about it.
But,
uh,
when I was a kid,
you know,
I watched the bridge of the river Kwai and uh,
their guns and never own.
And I also seen the marines hidden beaches and rangers getting wiped out and
they went,
okay,
if you're going to fight,
you want to get in something that you think you're going to come back with.
So that's why I became a frog man.
And,
uh,
we didn't go through buds.
It was UDT already under water demolition training.
So,
so you joined the navy.
Did,
did,
uh,
did you go straight to straight to underwater demolition?
Oh,
no.
Back in the day they wanted you to have an ace school.
So I got a bootcamp and 65 went to north island in core nautile for about seven
months waiting for my radiomen school and was lucky enough to go to 22 weeks of
radio one school and then went from there,
us as Paul revere for about four months and then went to a training and I
started turning January 6th,
how big was your class when you showed up to that?
There was about,
I don't know,
200 of us,
maybe,
maybe 150 how many guys made it?
There were about 30 of us that made it,
which was pretty good and it was colder than shit.
I don't know how you guys did when you went to turning Jocko,
but we made a pact that we weren't going to let anybody quit and we did
everything we could to make that happen.
So,
and some guys did make it through there.
We shouldn't have.
Yeah,
that's one of the,
that's one of the things I've talked about with laces.
You see that and I was never instructor buds,
but eventually you say,
no,
you don't want to help people through.
They're not going to make it through on their own.
You don't want him,
you know that you got to get,
guys are going to get through it on their own.
You know what I mean?
I figured I had a guy was a,
there was a previous fleet guy and he had been to bud's before and I became
friends.
He's a second class mature guy.
And I thought,
yeah,
this guy,
I'm going to kind of kind of follow his lead a little bit,
you know,
second night of hell week he quit.
I was just,
I was laughing.
I'm like,
go like,
here's a mature guy.
27 years old,
you know,
I was a kid and he's quitting.
Ridiculous.
So then you,
but when you got done with the initial Udr a,
you went to,
uh,
you checked into Udt,
right?
Yeah.
[inaudible] 12 was really funny because I'm,
me and our good friend of mine up in Flagstaff where he joined in,
we decided we're going to be marine.
You know,
his dad,
you Guadalcanal,
you name us,
uncles.
Did you use a marine?
But he talked me into it too.
So we went up to join the marines.
Well that office was closed and right across the hallway was the navy recruiter
and there was a both made of the line,
you know,
lean against the door and he goes,
what are you boys doing?
Oh,
we're going to join the marines,
you know,
which,
it's all good.
Yeah.
And he goes on and asked the other guy or what?
Your parents' background,
everything.
Marines,
marines,
marines.
So he knew what he was going to need to have a cue.
Well,
my dad was,
uh,
in the navy achieving Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
He says,
come here son.
So my buddy went off to be a marine.
I went in the navy
that close.
I think we all have a story like I know,
really close.
So yeah,
I had a buddy,
Bruce,
we were,
we saw like some,
some ship pulled in and we saw a guy's marine uniforms and we were like,
let's go join.
Let's just go,
Julie.
That's how effective that recruiting tool is.
Oh yeah.
So luckily I luckily live a longer open,
but the marines or the navy officers open,
so recruiting office
and so he showed up at Udt in what was the schedule there?
I mean the Vietnam war was already on.
So now it's like is it 1966 now?
No,
I didn't.
God got one into Udt 67 I graduated from training a single mile 1967 and that's
when I went over to hub Udt 12.
Yeah,
the word been on.
And then we had heard a little bit about seal team but it's still dead.
Nobody knew much about it cause we're everybody.
I graduated with East Coast and west coast.
You went to a Udt team first,
then you did a trip with Udt,
then you came back and got an sale team.
And how was that?
How was that first trip with Udt?
Oh it's great.
I would did a nine month trip and we had different debts that you went to and
uh,
in Vietnam,
like,
Oh,
first thing we did is go to Denang place called camp 10.
Sean.
We worked up at food way,
way quaint Tree Dung Hall all over the northern part of,
um,
of south Vietnam doing demo work,
different things,
you know what I mean?
And then we left that debt and one on the USS Diatchenko and we did about 110
miles of beach recons.
And then from there we went,
some of us went down to a debt and the,
uh,
Willow's hydrographic or,
or where they're just perpendicular,
perpendicular,
parallel,
not perpendicular,
but most of them are parallel.
We didn't do any perpendicular,
is that your combat?
You know what I mean?
But so,
so for those of you that don't know the original job of one of the original
jobs,
the Udt was to find out how deep the water is off of a beach.
So,
and obstacles and if there's any obstacles there that could trip up a boat
that's coming in.
And so you said you did 110 miles of the three months,
and so you basically you have to swim with a lead line.
So you have a,
a cord with a,
with a piece of lead on the bottom of it and you've got different markings on it
to tell you how deep,
how long it is.
And you sit there and you swim along.
Yeah.
Gray every 25 meters.
You have a beach party on the beach and it has a swimmer line going out.
And we added hooked to an IBS in case we got interest from that.
Ibs could turn and get us out of there.
We all grab onto the course.
It was only nine and a half horsepower ranges.
So you didn't go out very fast.
And we are able to swim fast every 25 meters.
You'd take sounding,
sounding soundings when you got back to the Diatchenko,
then he could tog refer,
which I was lucky enough to be one.
You'd go up a hydrographic charts right when I got the Udt 12.
Um,
you know,
you're pretty regimented and I'll call it budget as you,
Tory Burch,
you're pretty regimen bud.
When we got there are per tunes aren't even formed up and you were kind of lost
at sea.
You know what I mean?
Nobody's really telling you what you have to do.
You're not in a petunia at.
And it was kind of kind of floating,
you know what I mean?
You went up and did a um,
lifeguard stuff for the marines when they did land dunes up by Pendleton and
stuff like that.
It wasn't really a lot to do.
You know,
we're going to Jesus,
you know,
played volleyball lots and stuff,
ran around your UDTs and oral boots,
you know.
So,
uh,
then we started forming up,
how Udt worked is that you'd,
they'd be home for nine months and then the whole team would deploy in,
relieve the team that was out there.
Like we relieve Udt 11 and 11 would come back.
Nine months later they would come out and relieve us.
So it was a nine month deployments and almost port and starboard,
you didn't have like a year.
And a half,
two years of workup.
It was about nine months,
months with a workup.
And there was the workup.
W w what did you do during the workup?
Oh,
we did everything
saying we did recons we did demolition raids.
We did a river recons who we,
uh,
just how many guys were in a Udt platoon.
18 or 20.
I made,
it might've been 20.
It was quite a bit because you've got the swimwear line,
Beach Party and all that other stuff.
You know what I mean?
We did the old guard platoons.
We always try to get a couple extra guys cause we needed him to cover more
beach.
Same deal.
Yeah.
And uh,
everything you did and we'd do a just,
it was just a lot,
you know what I mean?
And it was a lot of physical work to,
Everything.
You need key.
Actually when we went through training,
I think we did about 50 times more swimming than the guys doing buds now.
Cause that's what we're,
we're,
we're frogmen so
more women than we did a bug.
That's a lot of this weapon.
I'm glad I went through buds instead of that while don't surf out there and in
January it's pretty cold.
There's no doubt.
And when you were there,
you were telling me before about some of the kind of hooking on to some of the
conventional units or some of their operations that they did with the,
I think it was the ninth infantry.
So we were down
in the delta or no,
we were doing river recons and I think we're the only ones that ever did with
this.
They called him the darts and it would look like a jet ski,
but you laid on it and you guide it with your feet and it had a 355 degree
camera up on top and the fat domino in the bottom of it and it had a piece of
aluminum.
I like this.
Of course we wouldn't get hit with the props and stuff and the handles were are
on the right and left,
you know what I'm saying?
And they went up to about 30 knots.
What they would do is take two of us,
either by chop or something,
drop us in a canal and we'd come down that canal.
Then we got back,
we do a,
uh,
a charter of that,
of that canal and a that would let the 19 inventory in their riverine boats?
No.
If they could go up there and do a land unit,
not,
not.
That's one of the things we did.
Of course you only went down on the river maybe once or twice and you didn't,
I don't want anymore.
Would you care for,
would you carry like a sidearm when you're on that?
We had a 45 in the front of the cover there and that's what we had.
We had a black jacket on,
a helmet,
UDTs and Gajda whether she would you do it at night or in the daytime?
Daytime.
Oh,
daily.
And then you know,
with would that 350
degree camera across a canals coming into pagodas.
Anything that was a known thing you could find on a map would take a picture of
as we went down,
you'd tried to stay at the same speed all the way down because otherwise your,
your chart wouldn't be good,
you know,
but we could really did that and we couldn't do it too much.
So,
uh,
I mean just a different rivers and different canals and stuff.
So we got bored.
So we started going out with the ninth,
10th and tree on those river boats to be their demolition guys,
blow up bunkers and sometimes they'd put log dams across the river.
We blow those up and stuff.
And I mean,
we took some heavies on that,
doing that.
So it looks,
so what kind of situations did you get in when you were,
when you're riding up with a ninth infantry?
Well,
we got caught in an ambush one time.
They usually had about seven,
about five,
six,
seven boats.
They had a bolt in the front called an Alpha Bolt.
It looked like your old monitoring,
the civil war.
And then they had um,
um,
like the landing craft they had those were bar arm or on the side.
Then they had a fifties up on top and back there that build up and they had bar
armor so that if a B 40 rocket punch you in,
they had rural,
thick styrofoam so that it would just be channeled into one area.
If they hit him from the sites,
then they had thirties to thirties on each side,
each one of the landing craft type of boats that they put the troops in.
And right in the middle of that was what they call a monitor new scene that that
was,
that's over and CISM field.
That's a great big boat.
And then to back they had another Alpha bolt and then all the ones in between.
So who was the,
was it one of those navy boats where they army boat,
the navy as a navy guys doing that?
I wouldn't have that job for anything.
Yeah.
So anyway,
we just going up and a group had won it before,
has dropped their people off and they came right by us.
As soon as we got by him,
uh,
they opened up on us and it was a bad day.
We had a 30 [inaudible] 70 wounded Americans.
Yeah.
And like the Alpha bolt head of us,
everybody.
But one guy was killed on it and that boat was floating by and he stared at the
American flag flying.
And there's one guy on the back on the 30 still shooting.
I mean,
you know,
there's no one wants to cracks me up when I not cracks me up.
It tears me up when I think about that.
But it was just,
that's the American finding guy,
you know,
that's the way we are not give those riverboat guys all the credit in the world
on those tango boats because they're just sitting targets,
you know?
And then after we got hit,
of course,
uh,
we all got,
we were in the fourth bolt back and we heard number one bolts hit.
That was the Alpha boat number two boats hit number three boats head.
We're number four,
but there were three of us.
Udt guys not voting.
I remember looking over a guy named you going,
we're fucked.
Excuse me,
I shouldn't have said it.
Anyway.
Then we got head blew us all down and stuff and I've of we buddies,
I had about 53 pieces wrapping him.
So I called over to him and hit him with morphine,
got up in the navy.
God got blown off as 30,
you know,
so I shooting that until I ran a rounds and shit.
Well the other guy,
um,
no,
that was,
I got here,
the other guy y'all messed up so he goes over and didn't see my pins,
who was call her.
So he had seen with another,
they're showing the morphine he lived though.
And then
who got a,
we just started shooting or the sides and stuff in the army guys who wouldn't
get up and shoot it.
They're handing us up weapons issue.
Well,
an old numbers and giving them to us and we were up there hammering
and you know,
sometimes you get a frogman.
Yeah.
Then the cobras came in in a army cobras and hose everything down real good.
So would they,
were they doing like an actual landing?
That's not,
the purpose was,
and they were going to get a beach foothold.
Work in area for awhile
can make a sweep through there.
And don't ask me why the marines weren't doing it.
And when they had the nine,
10,
I tell you why the marines weren't doing it.
Was there a holding the DMZ up in north?
They shouldn't marines,
that's their job.
But the ninth infantry did a good job.
They are good troops.
You know what I mean?
Well,
you,
I know you haven't listened to this,
this podcast much,
but I know you have,
you have read the book that Leif and I wrote and you,
you know,
that I have nothing but uh,
nothing but the most order,
highest respect for the marines and the army units that we work with were just
phenomenal.
And the sacrifices that they made and the bravery they showed on the battlefield
was unbelievable on a daily basis.
So I know it's definitely something you'd think about this.
Now,
the training that we went through just for Udt to start with,
and then I came back from the dean,
went through seal team,
so you get all the,
what you guys call SQT.
We'd call it a category back in the day,
and then you go over again.
You've already had your feet and a gun.
Now you figure he's armor guys go through basic training and a lot of them had
viral to Vietnam.
You know what I mean?
And they could be in a Shau valley anywhere and and where where the crapper you
get the hit the brick and you imagine that we had the training,
we were volunteers,
we've volunteered for war,
we're going to do,
we weren't just saying,
here you go.
We knew exactly where we were going to go and we wanted to go.
You know what I mean?
Oh yeah.
Big differences.
No.
Another weird thing about Vietnam,
and I've talked a lot about Vietnam books from Vietnam.
There were Vietnam here and you know,
the fact that these guys would rotate out,
you'd be in the middle of a deployment.
You just,
you know,
guys,
we're just rotating out all the time.
You know,
it wasn't like what you just described,
what you did in the seal teams and in Udt and what we still do in the seal teams
now is you get with your guys,
you go through a workup with those guys together as a team.
Then you go on deployment together as a team and you come home together as a
team.
And the army guys,
they would just,
yeah,
they're just filling in the holes and the guy would go home and another guy
would take his place.
So he never worked with this.
You know,
you could have a guy on a patrol with you,
two or three guys you've never worked with before and you're going out on patrol
with them.
So it's a,
I don't that system.
I like the way we do it reminds me of Forrest Gump,
you know,
that was,
what were you good little fee?
What happened?
No.
The new guys that came into the platoon.
Oh yes.
Checking in.
Everybody had already been there already and they're just coming in.
They hadn't worked up with these guys,
nothing.
They were just showing up,
you know,
in Boston.
Then we actually did take a couple of guys in.
When I was in Ramadi,
we took a couple of guys that just showed up new guys and we just had to slowly,
you know,
we put them in the Washer.
Do you have people that were taken out?
That's why they came in and they were just guys that were filming and we did.
We lost guys,
but they were just guys that they,
they got sent to seal team three from SQT and when they got there there was no
one there.
So they brought him over on deployment.
A couple guys was like two or three guys and we just,
you know,
okay,
here's w we made him work in the compound for awhile and then maybe bring them
out.
They'd be a turret gunner on nop and maybe eventually get loved,
do a little bit more,
but yeah,
that's perfect.
Yes,
we should do it.
And so any other,
any other Reese?
Yeah.
So another time we were [inaudible],
we used to be on the front bolt,
the alphabet because there were the first ones that saw the log damns or it had
a blow up bunkers and shit.
And we had about
a big stack of c four in the back,
you know,
the average actually shit,
and all of a sudden the whole boat shook like this.
We've got to be 40 rocket right.
And one of the exhaust tubes.
And we started sinking.
So we give the Cox and ran it to shore and everything and we're shooting back
and everything but the fucking boat thinking and that it had been about another
Adh is hired.
It hit all that c four but we landed and uh,
[inaudible] we swam off and got out in the river and this other,
they called it a Zippo bone.
It was like to troop carrier bolt.
It was all napalm or not napalm,
whatever.
They go out in flames,
the worst,
you know,
flame thrower bolt.
And this ain't just weren't on the beach,
you know.
And we went and climbed up on that.
We got out of their day us than the crewman.
That was,
uh,
that was another moment of excitement.
You know,
it's,
just to go off of what you just said too,
and with the training that you get in special operations,
seal teams,
whatever,
Rangers SF is,
you know,
a lot of times we in special operations get a lot of praise for doing what we
do.
And that's great and everything.
But like what you're talking about being in a conventional unit,
it's the same thing over in Iraq and Afghanistan.
Being a conventional guy,
it's no joke.
I mean it's,
in many cases they're doing a much more dangerous job.
I mean even,
you know,
a logistics job,
something like that where they're exposing themselves on a regular basis.
So anybody out there that's a civilian at that thinks that the conventional guys
aren't doing,
you know,
aren't taken as many risks as a special operations guys.
I'm telling you right now.
They absolutely are.
And of course there's things that the,
that all special ops guys do that a step it up as well.
But everybody,
everybody pays a price and everybody takes a lot of risk when they go over
there.
And it sounds like it was the same thing when you had the ninth infantry role in
up the river.
You're good day.
I did get new jobs.
If I seem to say anything derogatory,
I apologize.
Oh No,
you didn't.
The boys were getting it all.
You didn't know.
I'm just pointing out a lot of times,
again,
people,
I'm sitting here thinking,
I'm thinking exactly what you just said.
Here you are,
you EDT,
you've been through all this training and you,
you know,
when that boat started sinking,
you're like,
Hey,
I'm going to jump on the swim.
There's regular army guys there.
They're,
they're thinking they haven't had the training that you've had and yet they're
still in the same,
almost the same exact situation.
Exactly.
So one other thing,
and Udt we're doing a beach recon and I was a cartographer,
so I'm up in front with another guy and um,
I have this big huge piece of plexiglass I'm doing all the backdoor information
on,
but I'm ahead of him.
We're putting in the stakes.
So the guys behind him,
he had every 25 meters and do their sound needs and stuff.
Well,
we didn't.
Usually we had Arvin,
which are your a South Vietnamese army or we had marines that would do screening
for us.
You know,
when we were doing the beach recons we couldn't get either one of them.
So he had to have her own guys doing it.
So they were walking,
going behind.
It was all,
um,
a lot of sand dunes and stuff like that on the beach,
you know,
trees,
little forest in itself while we almost walked right into an l shaped ambush
that they had set up for us,
except the two guys back here,
that aspire hole back here.
So that when we fell back from the ambush,
if any of us were still living in,
these guys would get us right.
Yeah.
They hit these guys.
So made them open up,
which made him open up earlier than we leap frog down and got out of there.
But that was a,
that was a few moments of excitement too.
And that's when I got back to the U S die.
She ain't gon,
I went,
you know,
screw this a naked warrior shit.
Jimmy has sexy and carry me up and let me go out and hunt these guys at night.
I don't like running down the beach and UDTs and you know,
my choral boots shoot an m 79 been heads down and shit.
You know what I mean?
It was a,
but I was just Udt then so I didn't talk too much about it.
You know,
it wasn't a seal.
So you get back from that deployment?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Every month when I was on the deployment mean a guy named,
we'd put in a chip to go to seal team when they had just your asses out.
He ain't going anywhere until we get back,
you know.
All right.
So we'd wait a month and put another chit in.
Well,
when we got back poon we weren't right to,
uh,
um,
cadre go and checked into seal team one and then one and two a cadre
and the cadre training was,
was what we call now the estimates,
the Slt,
your ids,
that stuff
in the,
actually on the Alamo River.
And a few other places.
They had it set up to be exactly like it would be in Vietnam with watch your
little watchtowers and they had a whole um,
uh,
village that was in amongst all the shit that's on the side of the Alamo River
and stuff.
It was really good training.
Yeah.
And then we'd do that.
Ambush ass had Amboy,
Sam,
they'd come down in,
um,
you know,
sand pans we had there and stuff like that.
And just like on a,
you know,
and you do an ambush on a river,
you always want to try and do it at a curve and hit him.
So that way the sand pans after he hit him and stuff,
have flown to the bank,
not keep on going down the river and you can't get nothing out of him.
Just all kinds of little tricks.
And what they did,
our cadre at ran a,
through the,
uh,
our cadre of instructors were guys that had just gotten back and they pulled
them out of platoon to do that for about six months before they went back into
another Bluetooth.
So we were getting continuous guys right out of the field and Vietnam,
which is all good in different areas to the triple canopy shit,
you're mangrove stuff and you know the rice patties and all that stuff.
Like you do a bulk of the training.
Oh,
out at an island.
And then we'd go up to Queer Maca for map and compass and stuff.
And then a bunch of us went through a,
what they called CEO advanced training,
which is for your approved program,
which was a five months long in that though is all tradecraft medical and stuff
like that.
And really,
really good,
uh,
gut really honed in more even on the ids and stuff like that.
And we,
we took trials until trills all kinds of stuff.
Yeah.
It's interesting as you talk about that,
how much of that stuff you know,
carried on to you?
When I showed up at seal team one,
you know,
we did that all,
we did booby trap trails,
you know,
there was no one,
it hadn't been a war going on for 20 years when I got there,
the old and the Gulf War.
But we still did booby trap tales.
We did point man courses,
we did the medical stuff,
we did river ambushes.
I mean it,
it's,
it's awesome that that in,
there was no,
it wasn't really written down anywhere.
Two weeks of advanced demo on kitchen table demos because we set all that up and
she'll keep one.
I know what you had.
She had a show been going.
That's awesome that it lasted that long,
you know,
with,
no,
cause the weird thing about seal team is we didn't used to have anything written
down.
I mean it was barely anything written down.
And so all that,
all that knowledge was passed word of mouth from guy to guy to guy.
And that's,
I think we've corrected that now where we capture more of the stuff.
But you know,
you ever one flight rangers get the range your handbook.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's the only thing I had against that a little bit.
It still should stay in house.
It should be rolled down.
But you know what I'm saying?
I don't,
you know,
and give you a ranger handbook can you can find out exactly how those guys are
going to fight,
what their methods are.
Everything.
Another thing I've talked about on here is when you have doctrine and you get
tasked with something that's not the doctrine and you get confused,
you don't know what to do.
That's one of the,
that's one of the reasons I think seal teams have been very successful in the
recent past.
A even in the,
even in the longer past is because we didn't have a book to look at.
We had to figure out how to do it and so no matter what the mission is,
we always had a fresh look at it in a damn.
We're an Orthodox way,
right?
I mean,
you know our guide you,
if you had pulled a platoon right out of Vietnam and put him in Ramadi or
somewhere would have been lost at sea because we didn't have the training for
the urban type of warfare.
Yeah,
I know you wouldn't have been lost at sea.
I know you would say principals are the same.
The same principles that you guys taught me was the same thing we did over
there.
Have figured it out over move.
Take the high ground.
Yeah,
we would've figured it out,
but you know we didn't have Overwatch is and stuff like that.
When it's pitch dark at night and you're working your way through real quiet,
not making a lot of noise.
Yeah.
Everything you do is we're,
you know,
being,
being silent or just like you guys never had to do things like,
you know,
in a real town line,
the point scout did well,
he had to step over and grabbed the guy behind him,
bring in his hand down,
showing where that wire was and he had step over the wire.
He had put his leg over and grabbed the guy behind him and that's how we got
across until we get everybody across and got a head count,
they would move on.
That's just who we trap stuff.
You know what I mean?
We that,
that's just a new did it and you couldn't see it was pitch black.
That's where he grabbed the guy's hand,
children where it was.
And if it's a Taiwan,
you don't cut it.
If it's all losing stuff that how old the wool,
the point held the point man.
See that now you had what they called,
we used,
um,
you take a twig ruling on a real,
no,
no string on it,
but just like a fishing pole and used to run that up and down like that.
We moved and you'd feel it.
You can feel it just like you would if you've got a trout or a bite and then you
work your hand down,
you Rico there and feel and see what that is.
Yeah.
Ninja.
You went the other,
the other interesting thing that when you started talking about seal team and
going out at nighttime and how that was all unorthodox and people weren't doing
it,
is the opposite of what when we were in Ramadi,
we started going out in the daytime.
And the reason we started going out in the day,
there was a bunch of reasons why we started going out in the daytime.
But one of the main reasons was the enemy knew that we own the night.
We had night vision,
we had there,
you know,
we,
we own the night.
And so they didn't want to go out at night until they went out daytime.
That's,
and they tell planted their id just so they kill people.
That's what,
and so we went out the daytime because that's where the bad guys were out.
Datetime in Vietnam too.
You'd see guys sleeping in hammocks to share.
We'd wrap them up because I knew there they had been out at night doing shit.
So who we wanted to talk to him,
you know,
just like a rules of engagement and shit.
When we got,
uh,
my last platoon,
we stopped in Saigon and went to Mac for v and our Lt,
God has orders,
you know,
and his orders were pacify the vin long province.
Wow.
That was his orders.
Pacify the long province,
Roger that we went off and did it.
Yeah,
no rules of engagement,
nothing.
Just pacify it.
And it was like,
okay,
we didn't work for the army,
navy,
marines or anybody who we were our own entity.
So if you'd been the LTE over there,
Jocko,
you'd had,
you'd had the con,
matter of fact.
Yeah,
they uh,
were at Dong Tam,
they had a naval base here and then the big army base here,
Dong Tam,
they had a stay on the Vietnamese navy base in between them because the navy
didn't really want us on their base plus or bolts are right down there in the
war.
So it worked out perfect.
You know what I mean?
Then we'd go to the army to,
you know,
to test her west side.
Yeah.
And they were doing that all the time.
So it wasn't like,
you know what I mean?
It wasn't anything unusual,
So,
so going back now,
you get back from your first appointment with Udt,
you go to the seal team,
you show up,
you're going through the training.
What was the,
what was the,
kind of,
talk to me a little bit about this before,
but how were you getting treated because you got,
you got wounded on your first deployment as a ut guy,
right?
Yeah.
So here you are,
you're a combat veteran,
you've been in the shit,
you've been wounded.
We called it a Viet Cong achievement medal.
So,
so you shell up at seal team one,
you're kind of like,
Hey,
I'm a,
I'm an experienced veteran,
I've been through shit and didn't mean shit.
And they just,
the guys there,
how'd they treat you?
Well,
all right.
Just the same.
I mean,
I'd had a trip with EDT,
but just about everybody that when your team came out of Udt 11 or 12 into seal
team,
you know what I mean?
Back in the day before they started bringing them right into seal team,
the new guys,
you know,
so it wasn't any different.
There were guys there.
You just had to learn.
I mean,
I didn't,
you know,
when I was in Udt,
I'll tell you,
I wish I really wanted to go.
Like when we were Dong Tam,
that was during the 67 68 10 and we got a call that the east coast platoon,
the metal,
which wasn't too far away from Dong Tam was being overran.
Luckily they were up in a tall building,
so they,
they held out real good.
They were the tallest building and they had a 57 recoilless and you can hear the
VC coming up,
the stairways to throw grenades down and shit like that.
And they needed some help.
And there were about 17 of us down on that dark patrol on the USS Benoa right by
Dong Tam.
And we begged her,
Lieutenant Goddamn,
let us go in there.
We'd been fucking killed.
Our heart was there,
but we didn't have the eye,
a IED training,
immediate reaction,
you know what I mean?
None of that shit.
I mean,
we had been,
it would have been stupid.
So old.
He's our lieutenants had known we hated him,
you know.
Then I got back and went to a cadre or SQT and did all that stuff and then
deploy.
The next time I saw John Odie shy,
hugged him.
I said,
you are one smart son of a
vegetarian or heart was there,
you know what to be,
but Udt you'd just
trained to operate on land.
He didn't have the uh,
that prerequisite skills that you learned in SQT and stuff.
You know what I mean?
And you get,
he get more of that even in buds now than we ever got because we were trying to
be a frog man.
That was it.
I mean,
our last op,
we did it.
Thank you.
Many island and it was,
we swim scouted in by bird shit rock.
And I can tell you this shit I'm talking about,
they gave us 40 pounds of demo,
have her sac.
We went 26 miles down to the other end of the island,
blew up at target and come 26 miles back and attack the camp guys.
As we were patrolling that ambitious and they'd pick out guys had been killed.
Pretty soon we were all fold down and they'd go,
God damn it would tell you who he shot.
Then they get to go back to the camp and defend it when we came back and
attacked it.
But it was still just a demo rate.
Do you know what I mean?
It wasn't anything,
uh,
patrolling real good patrolling tactics and all that stuff that you learn.
You know what I mean?
Uh,
I mean like I went out with the Australian SAS in Nui did and did a,
um,
a week,
uh,
out in the field.
Oh,
as a week or was it,
yeah.
Uh,
my second platoon,
two of us,
we had the Aussies come down and work with us and they loved it.
Then we went up to Nui Dat.
That's a 60 guy.
We went up and went out with them.
We did a 10 day patrol with them,
resupply and all that stuff.
They never talked.
Said one word.
That whole patrol was all hand and arm signals.
That's awesome.
And they would,
they would get an ill,
you pee at night,
everybody with their feet out.
You need your lane on your pack,
have your weapon,
right?
Actually,
yeah.
Pull what they called the silk.
Yep.
And you'd go to sleep.
Well,
didn't sleep for about two nights because that's when we usually went out and
work.
Then we started to,
cause the way they figured it was in a real noisy area and somebody in that
circle would be awake and if we got sprung or something then you have 360 degree
fire power and we get out of there.
But they were the best I've ever seen.
I've been to,
I went to army ranger school rate of herb school and everything and that one 10
day patrol.
The Austrians,
I learned more about reconnaissance and I did anywhere,
anywhere.
No,
we know we used to have guys from the sis come to come to team.
I know.
Yeah they did.
We had that program for a long time but they were,
the last guy we had there was an officer and he wasn't worth a shit.
But some of the sergeants we had,
the guys that were there when I showed up were we're really squared away.
Guys that definitely had their field craft down.
Oh they're so good and fit.
That's what I was trying to say.
The field craft we did in Udt didn't have the field craft to be out in the
jungle looking for people and shit.
You know?
That's why in Udt 13 some of the guys got killed and stuff down trails and shit
like that.
They didn't,
you know what I mean?
Got to kind of have their shit together a little bit.
Yeah,
so,
so you go to the cadre training,
you check into your platoon and
it's time to go on deployment.
You are you flying?
Where are you flying out of flying out of North Island?
Yeah.
We fly out on North Island and my first book tune,
we flew into camera on bay and then took choppers down to a place called new NAM
can,
which is the very southern part of South Vietnam,
right by a place that called the human forest.
Do some turnover ops with the guy with the other platoons that were there.
No turnover.
We didn't,
we didn't at that time,
matter of fact,
most of our ops were dark board off's.
You ever heard of those?
No.
That's where you put a map behind you and you choose one of the guys and it was
a tune.
You throw a dark behind you wherever the dart hits is,
where you're going to go into.
Because we didn't have intel,
we didn't have shit.
We were pretty isolated where we are in a Vietnamese base camp and and BF,
Egypt,
you know what I mean?
So that's how we went out.
Is it,
what did you do in like a do an helicopter insert or a river answer?
Yes.
All River.
Actually out of a new Nam Cam where we were,
we'd take sand pans out because we didn't even have any MST support or anything.
That guys down at sea flow dead,
which is a ways away from us to our other squad was there and finally they
pulled us out of new Nan can because we weren't,
we were doing stuff but it wasn't,
it wasn't effective.
It wasn't real bad yet.
So they brought us down to see flow.
Then we started getting some good ops down there and you know,
what were those ops lights?
We still did riverine ops,
like we went down to a place called square bay and uh,
cause we heard there was a prisoner of war camp and stayed down there for about
three days watching this trails,
seeing if we could see him moving and stuff like that.
We'd do ambushes,
we'd get Intel from our navy Nilah which still wasn't that good.
Oh one of the things in 69 that was the first platoons and 69 was uh,
we landed at New Nam can got her stuff off the old 46 that Landon is there and
put it in the bunker.
And then this little loge came in and landed.
Do you know?
No,
I don't know his name,
but yeah,
he was,
he was approved guy in that province that we are in down there.
So he came in and told us,
yeah,
if you guys need anything,
just let us know.
And as soon as that load load load,
she left.
We got mortared for about an hour and a half.
So we told him never to come there again cause they knew what that loach was.
Yeah,
he was approved.
It was approved guys now great Ui.
But uh,
yeah.
And he was approved down long hair,
you know,
bearded,
the platoon setup was you had an OIC and AOI see a platoon chief and an LPL kind
of like what you'd run well,
what we'd ran into two squads,
the uh,
you know,
appeal and just like what you did.
Just the same one.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And then we broke it down.
You know what I mean?
You had your like,
uh,
I was with the AA OIC and the last book too,
and I was in,
was with,
uh,
with,
with uh,
it was my AIC.
Really?
Yeah,
that was a,
when was that 89 Pale.
Yeah.
No,
that's awesome.
But he was a Muslim it fun.
Yeah.
He used a great guy.
Awesome.
But I'm just saying he was hugely AOAC cause you always see,
we had the Lpo old work with him.
Then I would,
you know,
have a,
the kind of guy.
He was a senior chief then.
Yeah.
That's awesome man.
I don't know if he knew any of them.
They're all in my platoon,
my radio one horse radio when I ever had in my life.
You know,
I can imagine I went to radio school,
like I told you,
I guess he never carried a radio on the team.
Really?
You never carried a radio?
No.
As a 60 gunner until I made LPO.
Then I went to the m 14.
I like to seven,
six,
two round.
Yeah.
That's the uh,
that's kind of the stand when I went,
I went through SQT that they told us,
if you're not caring to item 14,
you're,
you're wrong.
Yeah.
That's a great weapon.
It's accurate.
It's perfect.
I love doing a bunch of guys.
Ramadi carried the m 14 as well.
Yeah.
Cause they're shooting,
you're shooting at vehicles,
you shooting do buildings shooting and he put the h,
the uh,
our AP rounds in there and you can dig through some stuff.
Yeah,
we did six months deployment and I did three deployments.
I did,
um,
1969.
I was in a Kalo platoon and then came back from that.
Then they actually got out for a year and a half because I was married and my
wife talking to get now.
So I did and worked for the phone company as a cable splicer painted everybody
and everything.
We lived in corn auto,
so I'd go down the trade winds and all my buddies would tell me what grade trips
or having stuff and I just went.
Now what year was that?
That was um,
[inaudible] 70 71 that was the only got back in 69.
So when you got back in 69 you got out for a year and a half?
Well about a year,
maybe not quite a year and a half,
but I went back in and gotten another platoon,
lack of lane and went to Vietnam again,
70 71 and I had
guys like that and that probably,
that was a great book.
Dune.
And what was that?
What was that now were you,
you were an Lpo.
That platoon,
no suicide.
Get in Africa,
but yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
And what was that?
Was there any difference between that first seal deployment to Vietnam?
I'm real happy with the first deployment because we just didn't do a lot.
I mean,
it was okay,
we did some stuff,
but it wasn't my idea of what it should be,
you know,
as a seal.
You know what I'm saying?
Oh yeah.
And then it was better when it got down to see float and it's still,
you know what I mean?
But that second platoon,
the one that kept me in the navy,
you know,
they were just,
uh,
you know,
we're a band of brothers.
You know what?
And we were so close.
It was unbelievable.
I mean,
I love those guys.
The,
the difference in what you did,
was it the missions that you got tasked with it?
The way that the platoon commander kind of set things up so that he had a better
vision of what,
what to do and what to get after?
Absolutely.
I was
then my second platoon,
that guy was just unbelievable.
I mean,
he was just a really,
really good,
our first platoon it was,
and he was kind of nuts who we didn't like him.
Like one time we're all cleaning or weapons on the sea float and everything.
And what we used to come back when off is grab a line,
then you jump in the water and let it wash all the mud off.
Yeah,
well he grabbed the line,
jumped in and we had music real loud and cleaner weapons and shit.
Well the line wasn't tied off right?
So he just started going down the river,
but they saw him in the watch tower and said,
man overboard and went and got it.
You know,
something that,
something that we talk about on here and I sub I've experienced is his album
blue on blue situations take place.
And it's really hard for people to understand how it happens.
But I know that you had,
you had one of those happen.
You want to kind of give a quick debrief on that.
We're about ready to go home.
We had a new platoon come in.
They wanted to do a breakin up,
not mentioning any names of the officers,
but they wanted to do a hammer and Amro up,
which you just don't do with a brand new platoon.
And we'd been there.
We had our stuff together pretty well in that area.
But what it was was we were supposed to push these bad guys to the VC into these
guys that were in a tree line and they inserted,
it's at the wrong place to start with.
So when we started working our way in,
we kind of came up to this tree lane where it ended a rice patty.
And then there was another tree line.
I couldn't give you the,
it was a halfway decent ways away,
you know what I'm saying?
But we had three kit Carson scouts or this kit.
Carson scouts were north Vietnamese that had,
um,
gave a turnover over to the south enemies and they put them in camps and they
called them a chew toy camps basically.
And what we would do is we'd go to these camps and we would get these guys that
knew our area that we're working in and through an interpreter and stuff,
we'd brief and everything and they'd come and work with us and they'd work with
us,
run a couple of obstacle.
They became kind of trusted agents and they were pretty good.
Most of them were nor a on not north Vietnamese,
the VC that were good fighters,
you know.
And then we,
they lived with us the whole nine yards.
We paid them,
we had money from a now for B,
they gave us a lot of money to pay these guys and stuff.
So they weren't doing it just for free,
you know,
cause they needed money for their families.
And I don't know,
the atrocities that happened to their families is one of the reasons a w two
void and came to our,
uh,
to the South Vietnamese.
I,
anyway,
we had three of those guys out in front of us.
Black Pajamas,
AK 47 looks just like VC,
you know,
so the brand new platoon saw three guys coming out of the tree line that were
VC.
So they opened up on him,
killed two of them are wounded.
The other one we swung off to the left and laid down and they were shooting sex.
She's and stoners status.
But Shit was just falling on their heads because they were shooting high like
new guys generally do before you,
and that was a pretty new brand new guys and apple tune,
you know,
they weren't experienced and shit.
Normally you'd walk him in whatever,
you know.
So we're yelling the radio,
cease fire,
cease fire.
And we had our officer that was with us,
got up on his knees and shoot back at him,
a gunshot to the heart.
Then we finally got him to stop and then we got him out of there.
He was dead though.
He shall right to the heart,
you know,
that was a blue on blue thing.
It was pretty bad.
And that was right before you went home.
Yeah.
The confusion that happens
breaking up and you know,
and like I say,
the new,
the new platoon had about two guys,
I think they're Lpl,
can't remember his name.
And then it was with me on that beach where we got shot off.
He was also in my training class.
He was the,
uh,
either the OIC or Aoac on that,
but most of the rest of them were all brand new guys.
You know what I mean?
Good training and everything.
But you know,
this is their first off,
God damn were in a firefight.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Anytime you get the opportunity to slowly work into the combat situations,
you know,
do a smaller patrol,
do an easier patrol that's going normally.
Did he not care
variety.
You're uh,
officers that you got,
you know,
take him out in the daytime.
That was a daytime up by the way.
But usually it's just to kind of get them oriented to the environment,
what they're going to be on an,
and then we all had these,
uh,
I don't know if we had one in 69,
70,
71,
we had these barn dance files and every opera we went on,
we'd put a synopsis in this Barn Dance.
So if you were going to go in that same area,
he could pull off that barn dance file and read it and see what the guys had
seen their enemy,
what the terrain was like a on and on.
You know what I mean?
It was a,
it was pretty good,
real good.
And almost every platoon had those from previous platoons all the way up to you.
So you can kind of get an idea of what you're going into if you didn't have
intel on that area.
What are some of the leadership,
you talked about your second platoon being super tight,
super close.
What were some of the leadership characteristics that you saw from the platoon
chief and the and the platoon commander that that as you look back you recognize
that those were really good traits that really brought everyone together.
Well
was our chief,
he meets senior chief and he'd been over about three times and it was just very
easy going but very sharp and the understood things really well.
Our LPL was Gary Smith,
she had Smith and he had been a pro advisor in that province or the advice.
So as far as getting in town all over the sides,
it was perfect.
And then,
um,
now I won't say much about him.
Pindar lt,
he was outstanding.
He,
uh,
went on almost every op fact one time he'd burned his hand with a smoke grenade.
[inaudible] we're still going to go out and he was going to go out with us.
He just had his hand wrapped up and shit.
So he has over key officers club on the navy side,
Eden and the officers are sin.
What your,
your hands all Ben.
He definitely shit.
You're still going out?
He says,
yeah,
if they get by my guys,
I'm dead anyway.
But he was really good.
He had to say he had his stuff together.
He was a just savvy,
just a head,
his head on his shoulders figured out things,
quick thinker,
you know what I mean?
And it was just a neat,
he was just good
it,
how about,
I mean,
you know,
we always,
obviously here now veterans get treated great now.
I mean from the Afghan war and the Iraq war,
we get treated really great buy for the most part by American and by the public.
We get treated really well compared to what you guys had to deal with Vietnam.
Well how much of that did you see when you'd come home?
Was it,
I mean,
Coronado is a pretty pro navy town.
I mean in San Diego it's a pretty pro navy town.
Was it the same way back then?
Was it relatively pro navy or did you see some of the,
some of the hippies and whatnot coming on and yeah,
some demonstrations sometimes.
You know what I mean?
Like a downtown San Diego could not much.
And we basically just hung out here in San Diego or to other bars that we knew
we'd fly out on North Island.
Fly in the North Island.
Wasn't like we were flying in the San Francisco or something.
So we didn't get hit with that real,
real heavily,
you know what I mean?
And if we did have issues at a bar somewhere,
we usually scare escorted away pretty quick,
you know,
so it wasn't really a problem.
We didn't really,
our guys here,
these ghost guys that don't know,
but our guys here where we didn't really have a have a thing,
I'll tell you an auto and a 69,
we were going up this one canal and we used a pbrs couldn't get up at,
so we had to take a Boston whaler up it with a twin six.
She's in the front and one guy would sit and steer the steering,
you know,
would take a squat up.
There may be five guys,
you know,
and whatever squad didn't have the opt night,
they got to be the driver and a gunner,
which I got to be the driver once.
And I wasn't happy.
I covered myself with flak jackets.
I mean,
who's anybody going to shoot that?
Oh yeah.
So we were going up real slow up this thing and all kinds of a filament lines
and stuff like that that we're cutting ourselves through.
Cause it was low tide.
Luckily it wasn't high tide,
you know what I mean?
So we got up there and,
and uh,
put the guys in and we came back out in the PBR,
said,
uh,
what the boats into a bank,
right.
So we're sitting there on the Pvr and uh,
my buddy that was the gunner,
another seal and all sudden across this river,
we were just pop up,
up,
up.
I was the sand pan,
so we're going to go after some bitch,
but one guy drive on one guy in the 60.
[inaudible] we needed a guy with,
uh,
that could see too,
you know what I mean?
Because you,
you know,
so we asked one of the Pvr guys,
who wants to go with us?
And this whole time we'd been with them.
God Damn,
we'd love to go out with you guys.
The only guy on that boat that volunteered was the guy that was married to him.
The rest of them wouldn't do it.
So,
uh,
we jumped in San Pan,
one after the other one,
hose them down,
they hit the bank and then there was blood trails going into the,
uh,
killed one of them.
He was laying in the boat and the other guy had gotten out and ran and he could
see blood spots,
you know,
following in.
Well,
we didn't go after him.
We're not that stupid,
you know,
nighttime,
he'd probably die in y'all take these fucker guys out with me.
Sorry.
We brought the sand pan back and God damn,
we had old big thing of Intel and weapons and all kinds of shit and the other
guys.
Then we went up and got the other guys bought them out.
They didn't do a thing.
You know,
it's pretty neat.
That's sketchy.
Yeah.
I can't,
I can't imagine the uh,
the,
that you guys would just go buy these filament wires and step over these trip
wires and just continue on your mission.
That's sketchy.
You have to
switch what we did anyway,
so I wasn't on Esop,
but it was,
and a couple of other guys from the other squad went down to score bay.
And um,
we'd gotten this Intel that the sand pin,
pretty good size one.
Um,
almost like a junk would go up the river at nighttime up the main river where
she flow was up by that way,
you know.
So George and those guys are down there they are again,
we're in a Boston whaler.
They had a couple,
um,
a law of rockets with him and stuff like that,
you know,
so they figured,
well shit,
we haven't raised,
been a dry hole here where thank God damn
that junk when it comes by,
you know,
so they go out after the junk and they could hear it and then see the silhouette
of an,
you know,
so he got real close to it,
fires uh,
far as uh,
uh,
La rocket and hit hit the stern,
not the exact rutter and everything.
Then popped a flare so they could shoot and everything.
Well after they popped there for about 15 other flares popped and it wasn't
there,
us.
So behind him was all this little flotilla sand pans and shit.
And so they took off and were shooting back where they're stoner and 60 and
stuff like that.
Finally they called and then a couple pbrs came down and saved them.
That was a pretty good offer.
Uh,
that's,
that's just so,
uh,
that's one of the major differences,
you know,
of us have a night vision.
Now,
the only way that you guys had to utilize illumination and we did,
we did utilize the lumination from time to time.
We actually,
uh,
on big,
big operation,
sometimes we'd have the army firing or the army artillery would be firing
illumination in certain situations.
But generally we weren't doing that.
Yeah.
And ambushes,
we always fired a flare up.
You don't get good vision.
He had where we had and then we got out of there,
you know what I mean?
It put a claymore is out and claymores behind us,
And everything sat with him for dudes to come down the river and then we'd get
him,
you know,
and then so you get,
you get back from,
from your second tour in Vietnam.
And is that the war ended right?
I mean,
this is pretty much,
in fact a
tuna now was that Ben luck,
which was 40 miles away from us.
They were only over there for three months and they came back to,
so we were the last full diploid diploid diploid Bluetooth in Vietnam.
And there was November platoon
was their chief,
uh,
lucky said
bunch of great guys and up a tune.
And
I mean at that time there was a couple hundred guys at seal team one,
I think there was about
maybe it had boosted it up real high.
So there might've been 250,
300.
I think there was only about 150.
When I got an,
I don't know,
off the big pushers.
Started yet to build more guys up.
There wasn't a lot you knew everybody.
I mean it was a pretty tight tight group.
And one of them,
one guy,
uh,
that we both know,
he,
he told me when he checked into seal team one back then he was like taking a
shower after PT and like every guy was shot up.
But you could just see every guy was,
you know,
you could see scars and their arm,
leg.
Swooned did,
did you,
did you want a lot of guys staying in at that time?
A lot of guys doing a couple of tunes get after the,
no,
most of the guys stayed.
And that's what we did.
That's where we logged.
And then after the war,
yeah,
we had a pretty good,
uh,
accidents and people getting out and when they get out because there wasn't the
dude,
you know,
that's,
that's what they were doing.
That was there,
you know,
there's nothing else.
I mean,
what are you going to do?
You know?
And uh,
I in,
cause I just liked the guys I like,
oh,
we did,
you know,
and uh,
like when I was over buds,
I come back in the 70,
71 and then went over to budget as an instructor and I got bored doing that.
So there's this guy called [inaudible].
I'll tell you,
I would not want to be an a student when you are bored as a Bud's instructor.
I was a nice guy.
But anyway,
so,
um,
it would buddy doll was in UDTs,
well
Betty Guy from Colorado and use a rodeo rider,
right.
So he talks to me and they're going out this place called Burton's,
which is out by,
um,
wasn't lakeside.
Ia was a lemon valley or Lemon Grove Levin goal.
Yeah.
And there was a place called burdens out there and it was just all bowls,
but they were dinks,
they weren't real.
Your Rodeo Bulls,
you know.
So I went out there and hell I liked,
I never got bucked off there.
So I went rodeo and went a IRA.
Then Prca key in actually thought about getting out of the navy to ride Rodeo
because I loved it.
But then I got bored because Rodeos,
bowls or rural balls,
they were the last of the
event,
right.
So I started riding bareback again,
saddle bronc too.
But the,
um,
I got stepped on.
Why you get 22 stitches in my left side of my face,
14 in the back of my head and had both my shoulders dislocated.
What else?
Got Gordon.
And then it got stepped on and had five busted ribs and punctured lung.
So I figured,
okay,
that's enough.
I quit doing that and just ate the teams.
You know the teams are safer than Rodeo.
Well that was over over a year and a half,
almost two years.
So it wasn't bad.
Yeah.
And what about,
what about guys and mean how are guys doing as far as handling what they'd seen
and coming back and all of a sudden they're in mainstream?
Dude,
we didn't have that problem.
I mean,
I'm telling you,
the guys that we're crazy,
we're crazy.
Before they went over,
they worry that they weren't,
uh,
I mean,
I know all my buddies.
In fact,
a Thursday,
this Thursday night,
we'll have that a UDT Vietnam Udt.
She'll get together on Thursday night.
I talked to those guys.
You don't,
you don't see,
but buddy going,
you know,
I've got to go to the hospital.
I'm mentally ill and not that I know of.
I'll tell you,
there may,
maybe it did happen,
but the only guy I know that really got affected was he was with that one
platoon.
I can't think.
And they've,
uh,
and they were taking a part of mortar in the mortar blew up and he had just left
to have a cigarette and all of his buddies got killed by the mortgage and stuff,
including a guy named [inaudible] who was just a superb guy.
And he wasn't quite the same after that.
And I can understand that.
I mean not,
you know what I mean?
But just being the firefights and shit like that and stuff that happened.
Nobody,
uh,
you know,
we just,
it was the way it was.
And even when you,
even when you got out for the first,
so,
so then you did,
you did 30 years in the navy and uh,
you know,
it was another funny thing when you,
when I talked about earlier,
when you,
when you graded,
are you lane graded me for the first time?
I don't know how old you are.
It was 1993,
maybe.
[inaudible] 90.
I was in,
uh,
Alpha tune at team one with a,
yeah.
Yeah.
But you were,
I don't know how old you were in that time period,
but you know,
for,
from my perspective,
you would like 170 years old,
right?
Yeah.
And I'm thinking to myself,
Hey,
this guy's deal,
this,
this Roger Aid and you are putting on your wetsuit.
Okay.
Put It on the wetsuit.
I guess you're going to get in the water,
gets in the water,
swim in,
do the recon recon in any swim back,
ran back out.
You know,
that's,
that was do
you have to do,
if you're going to do all reads,
you've got to do them right.
You know,
go point a to point B,
otherwise you don't see everything.
You know?
And that's what I liked.
I was a warrant then,
but that's what I liked my last three or four years,
three years I think in the,
uh,
in the teams as I did.
Oree so you still got to have your feet on the ground,
on the boys,
you know,
he couldn't be in a platoon would suck,
but that's the way it was.
No,
there's nothing,
there's nothing better than a,
there's nothing better than the,
uh,
than the platoon life.
Now I know that,
I know that you're short on time and I,
and I,
I rushed this and uh,
I'm glad we were able to get a little bit done and I think maybe after,
after this one and we get to listen to it and I'll probably end up with a bunch
of more questions.
I know people that are listening to this budget team guys listen to this there.
They actually,
a bunch of team guys sent me a bunch of questions.
I didn't get to any of them.
Yeah,
we were.
I know.
It says,
I'm sorry.
No,
it's all good things that pop up in your head when you're talking about him.
You know what I mean?
There's a lot of,
I mean I was at ut,
I was a frogman first and they'll see,
oh,
you know,
that was probably one of the best appointments ever had and that was great.
And Philippines is great and we're so glad to leave the Philippines and go back
to a debt just to get an hour for a while when we could have died,
you know.
So uh,
I will definitely get you back on here and like I said,
next time I'll,
I'll,
I'll get some questions from the team guys that they asked me to ask you and go
through some of those.
But thanks for coming on.
I know,
like I said,
I know you've never,
never been out in the public eye before and that's just the epitome of a quiet
professional that,
that we were all raised on and I appreciate it.
Like I said,
you're a hero of mine.
You're a hero of the seal teams and you're really a hero to everybody in this,
in this country.
And if anybody out there wants to continue this conversation,
you can,
you can get echo.
Charles and I on the social media echo is at Echo Charles.
I am at Jocko Willink.
We're on all the different social media,
Twitter,
Instagram and the Facebook.
If you want to support the podcast Echo Charles,
how can they do it?
If you
want some supplements,
the kind network obviously,
um,
on it has the best ones.
So you go to [inaudible] dot com slash Jocko you get 10% off.
That's one way.
Also,
before you do your Amazon shopping,
of course,
go to one of the websites,
right Jocko store or jackpot gas.com.
Click through the Amazon link there before you do your shopping.
Or to make that part easier,
we have this,
the trooper tool.
It's just this little extension thing you can put on your browser.
You get that on any other websites as well.
You just click on,
it's called the
Jocko store trooper tool.
Chrome extension.
Just click on that,
confirm it's on there.
It'll automatically do it for you.
So don't be so you don't have to remember.
It's good.
Um,
also if you like the shirts that we boom,
that's the ones discipline equals freedom is a good one.
Um,
but yeah,
I get some of those.
That's how you can see pork.
Awesome.
And,
uh,
you can get the book that Leif Babin and I wrote that actually Roger did the
security clearance on you didn't I just reviewed it for a four year thing.
You know what I mean?
Nobody thing.
But uh,
one thing I will say,
you know,
and I don't think I'm a hero,
I just went over there and did my job,
had a lot of fun.
This was a great guys.
Yeah,
that's about it.
Well that's one of the things that makes you a hero and thanks.
Thanks for coming on the show.
And,
and also if you don't know where we're having a little,
a little conference out here in San Diego,
California,
October 20th and 21st is not going to be for everybody,
but if you want to get in the game,
if you want to do something that's going to be intense to focus.
When we talk about leadership,
when they talk about getting better at what we do,
come on out the monster October 20th and 21st.
Roger,
thanks again for coming on the show.
Thanks for everything you did serving this country in Vietnam and spending the
rest of your life supporting the seal teams dedicated to our country.
And like I said,
Roger is kind of an unknown veteran.
And I would like to take a moment to thank all the Vietnam veterans that fought
with courage and with honor in a hard war,
in an unpopular war,
and not only fought for freedom against the evils of communism,
but also establish and passed on lessons learned for the current generation of
war fighters.
We owe all of you a great debt of gratitude for what you did for us and for the
United States of America
and everyone else out there.
Thanks for listening.
Thanks for spreading the word.
And as you go through life,
remember the sacrifice of these veterans that fought and sacrificed for us.
Yeah.
So that we can live
okay
with the sacred freedom to go out into the world.
Yeah.
And get after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko wariness.
True Hero.
Warren officer,
chief warrant officer seal
retired.
Roger aid
out.